JD what's it gonna be like when you're
dead I mean I don't think it's just
going to be black or whatever and I
think about it it's not even gonna be
black black that would be something yeah
it's not you're not even gonna see black
if you guys see not you're gonna have no
awareness what happens to you tell me
what goes through your mind when I bring
up death I see you're sweating and
rubbing your head it's just I you know I
think about just it just nothing I I
cease to exist and it depresses me which
would you prefer cremation or burial
I mean burial because maybe there's the
chance that could be a button you know
but did you want to live if you don't
even have grammar at this point rotten
bad I've been brought in mark I'm
awaiting on who do you want to spit
let's play in your funeral right now I
know it's gonna be hard it's fun to
watch you squirm who do you why do you
want your funeral to be who would you
like to speak I don't know [ __ ] have you
prepared a will no well now you have a
wife there's no reason for you not there
is one reason not to do it will have he
has nothing who do you want it your
funeral how would you like to see you go
friends with and family that's that's
you know whoever want to speak and speak
and what is this what not
I want not I don't want what nut you
mind your wife to remarry if you die
what would be wanted some of the most
valuable items in your wills or anything
of value that you own that you think
should be mentioned my dad my Johnny
Bench card from for
baseball cards - Wow Oh - from her hey
man I'm asking difficult questions if we
got to get this on record there's no
will what's your most valuable baseball
card I don't know I know I have a dirty
two rookie card the matter you head out
so you want
who do you wife will get the Derek Jeter
okay you want to leave her something
yeah I leave her my sheet i stain cheese
you can scrape him if you want to have a
baby
cheese you get real nervous talking
about you death huh so if there is an
afterlife and you come back as a ghost
do you want to like live in your
apartment watching your wife because
she's gonna be banging other dudes and
what if she looks like she's having more
fun right what if they're giving it
would be awesome if I was it goes to
whatever to travel ever do you want to
actually haunt the apartment and be
tortured for the rest of your ghost life
sitting there watching your wife bang
other dudes once you're assigned a spot
I think it works that you stay so there
rules well did you ever see in the
movies when the ghost doesn't leave the
house
I don't watch topper they were they were
condemned to that area it's like fish
you know they only swim around in one
little pool
they don't actually swim the whole ocean
what if she moved she he's that gotta
stay
bow or whatever whatnot boo and whatnot
boo and whatnot